the post-pandemic era Auto industry is
back and it's transformed more than the
new 2024 models
start the morning the Chicago Auto Show
the largest in the U.S revs back to life
after two years of smaller shows and
outdoor tracks we're finally back to our
pre-covered levels with two halls here
we've got almost all the manufacturers
returning there's a lot more cars on the
show floor there's really cool things
like airplanes on the show floor as well
the pandemic put kinks in the parts
supply chain reduced inventories and
drove the cost of used cars to record
prices now inventories are up and prices
well maybe not all prices are down
dealerships are adjusting to a new
paired down ERA with smaller lots and
bigger online orders and a widely
expected increase in sales the demand
for new cars the demand to actually get
in them and actually
kick some tires do some test drives
never really went away people always did
still want to buy cars during the
pandemic but they couldn't they
certainly weren't any available now that
that production started to come back now
the sales are starting to come back Auto
shows are starting to come back as well
the show is one part showroom one part
celebration with Planes Trains and
especially automobiles
along with a once again festive
environment even contact Sports have
returned sort of this year's Stars
include the new Corvette e-ray the
all-electric version of the classic
American muscle car one of a broad array
of electric cars a Toyota Highlander
that doubles as a Nintendo entertainment
center
in some EVS that aren't cars at all
one of the things that makes a car show
different from a showroom are concept
vehicles this Ram 1500 Revolution
battery electric truck might not come
out for years
but it's pretty cool
after a couple uphill years automakers
are looking for a smoother ride this
year John hendron Al Jazeera Chicago